Hi! In this video, we're going to look at brute-forcing logins with Burp Suite.
Although it's more efficient to first enumerate a valid username and then attempt to guess
the matching password, this may not always be possible.
So in this video, we're going to look at using Burp Intruder to attempt to brute-force
both usernames and passwords in a single attack.
We're going to use a simplified example here to demonstrate how to use the relevant features
of Burp Suite.
To run this attack on real websites, you'll usually need to bypass defenses such as rate
limiting.
For ideas on how to do this, check out the authentication topic in the Web Security Academy.
Before you start, you'll need a list of potential usernames and passwords.
For this demo, we've included lists you can use.
In practice, we recommend sorting the list in order of how likely you think the username
or password is to be correct.
You can follow along with this demo using the Username Enumeration via Subtly Different
Responses Lab from our Web Security Academy.
Once the lab has launched, try to log in.
On the Proxy HTTP History tab, find the request for submitting the login form, right-click,
and send it to Burp Intruder.
Go to the Intruder tab, and on the Positions tab, set the attack type to ClusterBomb.
In the request, highlight the username value, and click Add to mark it as a payload position.
Then do the same for the password.
Go to the Payload tab, and select Payload Set 1.
Make sure Payload Type is set to Simple List, and paste in the list of usernames.
Click Start Attack.
Once the attack has finished, study the responses for any behavior that may indicate valid credentials.
These could be a difference in error messages, different response times, or status codes.
In this example, we can see one of the responses has a 302 status code.
To investigate the contents of a response in detail, we can right-click and select Send
to Comparer Response, and also do the same for the original response.
Now when we go to the Comparer tab, we can select the two responses, and click Word or Bytes to
highlight any differences.
the first time, we can select the two responses.
The first time, we can select the two responses.